[Music]
lisa-marie finally opened the door the
fifth time she tried it was about
midnight her twins and her
fifteen-year-old were in her rusted
green Honda she drove to the yellow
brick house that she had found with a
unitedway hand on it the local shelter
knocked on the door she was safe for six
months they got her into safe housing at
a local co-op she thought it would be
great her twins were freaked out of
their minds her teenage daughter didn't
leave the room for six months she was
finally invited by some of the residents
to a basement where they were writing a
proposal for $8,000 to United Way they
thought after years of agencies trying
that they were going to be able to help
young people get to school ready do
better in their EQA Oh scores help high
school dropout rates and stop the amount
of times that the cops were coming into
the neighborhood and this group of four
women not only applied got the funding
from United Way but they started a local
childcare co-op they got Lisa Marie's
daughter out of her bedroom to start an
after-school program with 10 20 40 kids
they started community gardens and one
summer afternoon Lisa Marie got up to
receive the Canadian co-op
Federation award for the best co-op in
Canada and her first words were we are
who we are with and where we are with
them it's good to be with you here at
the YW a United Way partner on these
hallowed lands from the indigenous
community because you really are our
partners but this story actually goes
back a lot longer a priest a rabbi two
ministers and a woman advocate this is
not a joke I'm not doing got together in
this bar there was all kinds of problems
in this community their jobs were drying
up
marriages were breaking up people were
fighting people were drinking they said
we've got to find a way to solve some of
these community issues and in 1887 in
Denver these five came up with the first
United Way ever and they went around
with envelopes and their hands out
raising money and since then United Way
has been following that damn thermometer
and then about a hundred years after
that first meeting in the bar a United
Way in the u.s. said that's it
it's about community and every United
Way across the world started digging
back into community here in Toronto and
York Region the largest United Way in
the world we turned outward and we
started talking to residents community
groups about issues income gap early
learning mental health lack of social
housing you know all of the mallet
and what became very clear community is
the solution and we are not going to
fundraise social service or charity our
way out of this stuff if that's all you
remember about me today I hope you
remember that we are who we are with and
where we are with them community is the
answer and we are not going to fundraise
social service or charity our way out of
these social issues and so we in United
Way shifted from the thermometer to the
community and at the core of that shift
has been our research capacity our
commitment to community research in all
of its complexity some reports some
town-hall discussions and merging that
together to shape our work together as
we go forward
good old community work no drive through
accelerated solution no single bullet no
one agency no program that we're gonna
scale no one population that we're gonna
focus on community for slow lasting
measurable change and these six pillars
research first and then investment
evaluation strategy partnerships and
advocacy and research has always helped
us identify what the pressures were
across this region some of you will know
our poverty by postal code report which
transformed how we do business and where
we invest in the community
research allows us to build partnerships
and uprisings of care with others when
we released our precarious employment
report pep so it was a partnership with
McMaster Labor Ministry of Labour the
Toronto Star and most recently with KPMG
where we are using precarity as a tool
to engage with corporate partners and
shift their HR policies research forms
the basis of our public policy work
whether it's the vulnerable workers Act
that was passed unanimously at Queen's
Park or our recent work around community
benefits agreement we're in partnership
with Metrolinx and the province we are
ensuring that every Metrolinx project
from the Eglinton crosstown right across
to all of their builds will ensure 10%
of the workers come from that local
community that is policy and impact on
the ground and research has identified
how we invest in the community when you
think about poverty by postal code not
only did it shape our building strong
neighborhood strategy with the city but
it also led to priority neighborhoods
seven hubs that have been built and the
complete re-energizing of our agency
funding a few thoughts for you around
how we measure these results like so
many of you we measure the effectiveness
of our investment in a number of ways
and behind the scenes we fight like hell
on what is an outcome an output an input
we measure the number of people served
by our agencies the number of visits to
the hubs which equals now about 1.5
million people who have met at the hub
met other people participated in the hub
strata
we monitor the organizational health of
a fragile expansive network of agencies
that exist across the region but because
we are a learning organization we have
also taken our research into community
whether it's at our action for
neighborhood change partnerships with
residents across the region or a series
of meeting house conversations right
across this region church halls
basements where we have brought
residents together to talk about the key
issues in all of them what's become
clear and what resonates today is that
if we really want to change the
continuum for supports and and move the
needle for children we have got to move
the needle for children families
neighborhoods and we cannot do that
without looking at community in its
entirety we also know that our research
public policy agenda and government
relations are our single best strategy
to move government on large scale like
in the community benefits agreement to
make change so a quick example on how
research has influenced our work on the
ground the poverty by postal code report
released in 2004 examined the increase
between 1981 and 2001 in the number of
high poverty neighborhoods across
Toronto and how that concentration of
poverty was impacting vulnerable groups
not only were we able to work with the
then government of Ontario on their
poverty reduction strategy but early on
we completely shifted our funding from
the inner core of Toronto where the bulk
of our agencies were into what is today
a map of our funding across the region
which is a massive you right across the
suburbs interestingly about a decade
later we are not having to re-examine
if we need to put more services back
into the core of Toronto as it
intensifies and changes but thus the
value of our partnership and our
continued commitment we came together
with the City of Toronto to look at the
building strong neighbourhoods strategy
and as I mentioned earlier built seven
hubs with an additional hub underway
this report then led to vertical poverty
in 2011 which examined the growing
concentration of poverty in many of our
high-rise towers and in 2012 we launched
the tower neighborhood renewal
initiative which brings together
stakeholders to revitalize tower
communities the City of Toronto has
since reformed zoning bylaws to promote
neighborhood vibrancy and allow for
programming so that there can be
economic vitality in those neighborhoods
the last piece I want to talk to you
about in terms of our research a
cumulative of poverty by postal code -
the opportunity equation which positions
Toronto as the income disparity capital
of Canada right through to our recent
work around youth unemployment all of
that and our work on the ground in
neighborhoods is transforming how we
invest with our agencies currently over
five million dollars of our investment
goes directly to children what I'd like
to speak to you more about is the total
more holistic investment about two weeks
ago we announced a record eighty seven
million dollar commitment to programs
and agencies across the region it's a
record of investment about a million
dollars more than last year what's
interesting about this based on all of
our research is we are deepening our
work in poverty and geography
number one we have invested in 62 anchor
agency partners they will work with us
for five years and an up and down
strategy frontline support on the ground
community development in their
neighborhood and public policy and
advocacy and research as well because we
know that we're not in a social service
and charity our way out of this and we
need this inner core of 62 partners
across this region deep in poverty work
to to turn the needle on some of these
pressing social issues in addition we
are for the first time in a decade
opening funding for new programming so
that our current agencies and new
partners can apply under 9 program
streams from early years through to
mental health through the homelessness
for us to continue to meet the needs of
this growing region we have to maintain
work with our current partners but open
it up for new charities and supporters
as well you would know in all of your
work that for us to continue to make an
impact and turn the needle not only do
we have to have strong research but we
have to ensure that that investment is
following the data that summer day at
that podium receiving the co-op award
lisa-marie said when I first got here
nobody came out of their houses today 85
percent of our community is connected
and I feel like I belong belong it's the
most powerful word I'm involved in this
community I've got a part-time job my
twins are in JK ready to learn my
daughter graduated from high school and
is going to university on a scholarship
we are who we are with and where we are
with them and community remains the
answer Thanks
[Applause]